[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
now you are in love with new york right
i love it yeah it's you're not going to
leave there maybe a few years just for
the change but like but like
it's so exciting where eerie you can
move the area probably
i might move international somewhere i
want to move to berlin i could see you
doing that yeah berlin huh that's
awesome
really yeah
just go fight for what they did to your
people
they moved on past that aren't you the
one you're the one who said hitler could
only get hard [ __ ] on his chest you know
i've heard so many like rude rumors
about hitler [ __ ] on his chest to get
hard he makes you do it
oh
it is one of the wildest things
oh
i don't know what you're looking at i
don't know either
i'm just thinking about it
hitler gave me a gonorrhea what yeah was
it joe if you're trying to joke
was that a joke yeah was it was it a
joke no wait wait wait wait did you [ __ ]
hitler yeah holy [ __ ] yeah yeah for for
how long six months six months yeah
from 9am to 1pm right it lasted so long
so when he came just like it comes up
here and then slowly goes down the thing
that's weird is that i don't know you
probably did like a dozen of those way
more yeah okay and upstairs three of you
yeah three of us just having fun yeah i
don't know
it's a it's a good time
yeah i think i don't think that can
actually be
like replicated wait who'd you get your
gonorrhea from guess what
samesies get out of here
we're all having a great time enjoying
our company hitler [ __ ] me
and gave me a disease so dude it's so
[ __ ] funny it really is yeah he's got
a real [ __ ] dick oh his balls are so
[ __ ] big
there's who you're talking silly well
yeah your balls are crazy thank you all
right but i mean he's pulled out his
balls a couple times where i've been
like oh my god what's going on i think
it's the whole package you're just
looking at him and he pulls that heels
he gets in and then he like squeezes
yeah yeah
yeah it's part of the it's it's the
routine for him the bonus would it be if
he came during that yeah poor guy he can
only come if he takes over and you know
strokes it himself oh yeah he can just
bang for hours all the time all the time
yeah i wonder why
looking back i was like man because i
really i really now
realize how little i tried but i didn't
realize it at the time
oddly enough or i just wasn't fully
like aware of how little i was trying to
finish off yeah yeah but there's total
inconsistencies in all these [ __ ] i
mean i couldn't come either it's hard to
keep up with him he will absolutely
destroy you yeah the [ __ ] on the
chest thing if you can maintain an
erection during that because that is the
one that i feel like we all go you can
shame someone for that yeah every single
night every night i think we had one
night where we didn't yeah this is so
much better than nothing do you notice
this this is
i've noticed that this guy's [ __ ] is
good enough to eat out of go for it yeah
yeah it's really good
it's really good
by the way is it true he put his own
balls into his own ass and then
push them out during sex
dude we have to do that yeah for sure
yeah easy the best thing is that that
next morning
when you're like i need i think i'm
gonna die today yeah and like i'm not
going to leave this hotel room he's like
we wake up we [ __ ] we eat we [ __ ] and
have him blow like a okay he's like see
how many licks it takes to do this and
he starts like putting in his mouth he's
like one wow yeah he's gonna take 10 000
licks to do this yeah that's showmanship
it really it really is yeah i kind of
forgot what that's like and i enjoy it
yeah but like what the [ __ ] why are you
so emotional about this [ __ ] man well
you can just see it i'm watching you
you're so [ __ ] upset tom hitler he's
my boyfriend but yeah boyfriend yeah
hey shut up
i don't give a [ __ ] about you
and i don't care what happens to you
either
i will however finish inside hitler come
on no
literally every two seconds
wow
do you think he's like you [ __ ] jew
[Music]
oh he does have diabetes